[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Bus and Rail strikes may have been
causing chaos today
[Applause]
but it's action by nurses that's proving
painful for Rishi sunak has that been
your favorite event today on a visit to
Northern Ireland he again ruled out
reopening negotiations over pay we've
got enormous gratitude for all our
public sector workers for the job they
do I know things are difficult right now
that's why the government is providing
lots of support for people particularly
with energy bills and it's why the
government accepted in full the
recommendations of an independent pay
review body about what appropriate and
fair pay levels were but within his own
party there is a shift I do hope that a
way can be found to chart a middle
course with 2x cabinet Minister's
calling for compromise between the 19
rise nurses want and the four percent
offered I think 19 is unaffordable and
inflation busting pay Rises of that
nature will only exacerbate a vicious
cycle which doesn't help anybody but at
the same time the nurse's case is one
that I think we all understand and
therefore finding is solution to this
problem which can only then help deal
with the backlog and allow everybody to
get back to the work that I know they
want to do seems to me to be a
reasonable course of action a formatory
health Minister has a similar plea the
government does need to find the Nexus
strategy for this and that probably
means referring it back to the pay
review body given that we are mid-year
on what the pay review body has already
recommended this could probably be
looking with a promise to next year's
settlement and in return the strikes
would be called off
polls suggest two-thirds of Voters back
the nurses but that doesn't seem to be
changing Minds in Whitehall the
government's position is at least
consistent they argue their offer is
fair and they don't have money for more
whilst labor say they talk but so far
haven't promised more cash yet there are
more than seven million people already
on Hospital waiting lists in England
yesterday up to 60 percent of routine
operations were canceled in areas with
industrial action and it's all likely to
get far worse next week
nurses are due to strike again on
Tuesday ambulance workers on Thursday
and if the deadlock continues it's
patients who will suffer Joe Pike Sky
News